so we got two different people here both
with big dreams both very capable of
their dreams becoming a reality
one of their dreams becomes a reality
the other ones doesn't because at one
point
this person had a conversation with
themselves where they had to make a
decision
behind closed doors they weren't willing
to do it it's been a secret of their
life their entire life they've had it
they're going to take it to their
deathbed with them they will never share
with anybody else
and i'm speculating a little bit today
but i'm going to share it with you you
tell me what you think about this
but in order for me to make my point we
got to go back to maybe in 27 26 years
old
i'm in atlanta georgia i ran a sales
contest for my sales guys
when we go to atlanta this contest had
to do with a hot dog eating contest
orgasm who's gonna eat the most hot dogs
mario won seven hot dogs in a minute
another one was monopoly another one was
canoeing to see what can do a bunch of
people flipped on a lake
pretty ugly another one had to do with
horses anyways at the end of it
there was this house that the former
founder of the company i was a part of
had built and i wanted to see it and i
asked the
guy i was with have you ever been to
that house he says no i said you might
take me i want to see the house so we
get into the car
and we go to the house and we pull up to
the house massive massive house mass i'm
talking to
20 10 20 30 40 million massive house
we're talking about
and we pull up to the security guard and
i said i'd like to get it toward the
house
and the security says who are you i said
i'm patrick david and at the time i'm
coming up in a marketplace
i have a reputation in the insurance
industry of a guy that's coming up but i
haven't
made it yet so he said i'm sorry i can't
let you and i said i got to see this
house listen spin on my vision board i
got to see this house
so you can't see this as i say you don't
understand how life works with me
i got to go see this house so you can't
see this house
gates open boom i run to the door and
the door is a good 50-yard run
okay so i'm making a run for the door
security's chasing me it's me mario and
one other person or two other people we
walk up the other four like we're not
going to get arrested we round up by the
way i don't recommend you doing this
you got to hear the whole story before
you go out there and try something like
this so i get to the house i knock on
the door
and i said uh i'd like to get a tour of
this house i know the owner
can you please tell the owner i'd like
to get it toward us he's not here he's
out of the country
can you please call him so security what
do you want me to do with these guys
just hang on for a second calls the
security he calls the guy
the guy says i know who he is give the
tour the house i get a three hour tour
the house okay
by his brother kind enough to do it 26
27 years old
i get a tour of the house and i'm
looking and saying oh my gosh
my dreams are like this like this is
insane
i love this reminds me of iran when i
would go get a tour to shaw's house
we get in the car as we get in the car
everybody's like what happens you guys
get a recess and we didn't get arrested
we have toured the house for three hours
we thought you guys were getting dresses
and now we were getting a three hour
tour is what we were getting
back then there is no uber so he kind of
like said can he come pick me we got
they're 30 minutes away they got to come
pick us anyways it was a mess
but i leave and i say i'm gonna have my
dream house one day
and it's not gonna be like this because
i like the water i like privacy
i like guarded security with guns i want
i'm a military guy
i want all of that but i'm gonna have my
dream house one day anyways fast forward
in that moment there's a few series of
questions we all go through
you go through i go through all of us or
young dreamers go through
what's the first one how big are your
dreams number one
i write them down here's what i want to
do i also want to do this
also i'm not talking about dreams i'm
talking about big
lofty you know how they say harry b hag
big hairy audacious ghost like i'm
talking
massive dreams and goals not small ones
i write it down
i say i want to be able to have this one
there you can't have a path but i want
it
how do you think you can do it you out
of your mind but i want it okay great
so number one is how big your dreams i
wrote them out
number two how demanding is it
for these dreams to become a reality
what do you mean these dreams
if you want these dreams this level of
respect in a marketplace
this level of freedom in a marketplace
they come with a lot of demand it's very
very demanding
what does that mean today is fourth of
july
fifth of july monday everybody's on the
weekend i'm at the office here all day
today we're working we're driving right
with my kids here two of my kids are
here with me
they're doing their homeworks one just
finished the book the other one's
writing the abcs five times right
are you the demand how demanding are
your big dreams
very the next answer to the question the
next question is the technical one you
ready
are you willing to meet the demands
of your big dreams and that's where this
person says
i don't think so but when this person
makes that
decision nobody knows it it's subtle
it's very small it's very subtle and
they
start redirecting everything else to big
dreams is not not that important life is
not they have to convince themselves but
until they're
60 70 80 years old and they go to their
deathbed
and they remember that 35 year old
conversation when they were 40 years old
they had that camera whatever that
conversation was
that i simply was not willing to meet
the demands of my
big dreams this person also hit that
wall at one point
where they realize how demanding it is
how serious it is
this person said i am willing to meet
the demand
you know what happens what you think
about this the one question that this
person didn't ask
that this person asked and they got
deeper into it is the following a lot of
times people criticize me they say
pat's a store one the best storytellers
but man pat's so much about details and
the stories get
drawn out totally get it but to me i'm
about details
the last question is critical the
question is
how is it going to feel when your dreams
become a reality
go there you go there
whatever it is governor congressman
senator
billionaire millionaire founder of a
company taking the company public the
house the yacht the boat
the trips to travel the accolades the
respect the comment from your mom your
dad your teacher your professor your
enemy your competitor whatever it may be
big audition how's it going to feel in
that moment
if you can convince yourself that
feeling
is so insanely good then you
would be willing to pay the price that
the demand needed for your big dreams to
become a reality
but if you can't sell yourself on that
feeling
worth experiencing you're going to be in
this camp
but if you can you're going to be in
this camp by the way this camp is not
that busy
this camp is busy with a lot of
different people who did not want to
answer that question
and they don't want to meet those
demands so for you how's it going to
feel
like i give it to you from multiple
different areas you
people around you your legacy for you
the way you look at yourself in the
mirror to know that you said something's
going to become a reality and become a
reality
that level of respect is priceless you
can't buy that at walmart nordstrom's
name and marcus
or online you cannot you can only earn
that right number one
number two how's it gonna feel in the
marketplace the marketplace a lot of
people are gonna say man this guy said
they're gonna he's gonna do it he did it
this girl said she's gonna do it and she
did it
level of respect and salute goes to the
highest level of course more haters show
up
but even haters respect you you know
what's the biggest one
the legacy side is your kids if you do
it right
your next generation if you do it right
they're going to watch you they're going
to say man my dad my mom's fire i want
to replicate that and if you teach them
the right way
and you raise them the right way that
legacy continues if you do it the right
way
so yes at one point we all have to
answer one
four questions how big are your dreams
how demanding are your dreams
are you willing to meet that demand and
how is it going to feel if those dreams
become a reality
if the answer to those questions are
very big your right amount
very demanding you write them out i'm
willing to meet the demand
go do it and i want to experience
because i think it's going to feel
incredible
then you go pay the price and eventually
your big dreams are going to become a
reality
if you're watching the same path now i
just i just kind of want to go
experiences what do you suggest i do
next
i got a video specifically for you it's
called how to reach your full potential
if you've never watched it go watch if
you watch it you may want to watch it
again
because that formula has been a proven
formula for my life
constantly my life it's happened so many
times
i'm in the middle of the ocean yesterday
in fort lauderdale and when tom his kids
and my kids
in the middle of the ocean this husband
and wife run up to me while i'm with
tico dylan and senna
oh my gosh we follow that you don't even
know this
they're talking to me and they said we
took our business
from a half a million dollars to 10
million dollars a year
simply because the content we devour he
they said
i tell you i guarantee you no one's
devoured your content more than us
we are students of this business i'm
simply sharing with you stuff that's
worked for me
and my life hopefully today's message to
you inspires you
to answer one question are you willing
to meet the demands if you do
future looks bright take care everybody